Нові правила безвізу, продаж землі, судова реформа - у 2021 році на українців чекає багато змін.
Ось деякі з найважливіших нововведень.
З наступного року запрацює Європейська інформаційна система авторизації подорожей (ETIAS).
Це означає, що українцям та громадянам інших країн, для яких діє безвізіз ЄС,
перед поїздкою до Євросоюзу потрібно буде отримати попередній дозвіл на поїздку, подавши онлайнзаявку.
В ЄС обіцяють, що ця авторизація займатиме декілька хвилин у разі відсутності застережень у правоохоронних органів ЄС.
За кожне звернення заявник має сплатити комісію 7 євро. Авторизація буде дійсна протягом 3 років.
У ЄС запевняють, що нововведення не є аналогом візової системи і необхідне, щоб завчасно ідентифікувати осіб,
які можуть становити міграційну чи безпекову загрозу для Євросоюзу.
Нова система також має зменшити кількість відмов у в’їзді до ЄС безпосередньо під час перетину кордону,
адже подорожувальники знатимуть завчасно, чи не мають країни-члени ЄС застережень щодо їхньої поїздки.
Телефонувати по мобільному наступного року стане дорожче. Вже з першого січня ціни мають зрости майже вдвічі.
Приміром, тариф "Безлім" від Київстар був 95 гривень, а стане 175. Подорожчає зв'язок також у Vodafone та Lifecell.
Оглядачі радять перевірити свої тарифні плани
і за можливості змінити до 31 грудня на більш вигідні, інакше тарифний план буде обрано автоматично.
Варто уважно почитати умови переходу з одного тарифу на інший.
Подорожчання пояснюють необхідністю нових інвестицій у розвиток мережі та інфляцією в країні.
Також дорожчає електрика. Вже не буде пільгового тарифу на електроенергію 90 копійок
за кіловат-годину для населення на перші 100 кіловат-годин.
З 1 січня діятиме фіксована ціна для побутових споживачів на рівні 1,68 грн/кВт.год.
Відповідне рішення ухвалив уряд терміном до 31 березня 2021 року.
У Кабміні запевняють: якщо цього не зробити, ціна на електроенергію для побутових споживачів
мала б формуватися на ринкових умовах, що призвело б до різкого, більш ніж удвічі, зростання тарифу на електрику для населення.
Ці тарифи не переглядалися з березня 2017 року.
З 16 січня усі без винятку заклади, які надають послуги чи продають товари: від магазинів, заправок і банків до барів,
аптек та бібліотек - мають перейти на українську мову у спілкуванні з клієнтами.
Таке зобов’язання містить одна зі статей закону про мову, ухваленого два роки тому.
У випадку відмови закладами сфери обслуговування спілкуватися з клієнтами українською
спершу оголошуватимуть попередження. Якщо ж ситуація повториться протягом року,
то складатимуть протокол про правопорушення. Штрафи сягатимуть від 5 до майже 7 тисяч гривень, але виписувати їх почнуть лише з 2022-го.
При цьому жодна інша мова законом не дискримінується - на прохання клієнта його можуть обслуговувати будь-якою мовою.
У МОЗ затвердили план вакцинації від COVID-19. Українцям планують робити щеплення у чотири етапи.
Найпершими - з січня по квітень -вакцини отримають люди з найвищим ризиком інфікування та лікарі,
які працюють у стаціонарах для "ковідних" хворих.
Найімовірніше Українаотримає вакцини від компанії AstraZeneka,
враховуючи виробничі потужності цього виробника та українські реалії транспортування.
Адже більшість холодильників для зберігання вакцин за наднизьких температур,
зокрема від Pfizer/BioNTech та від Moderna, в Україні зношені та непридатні.
А вакцину від AstraZeneka можна зберігати і за плюсової температури.
Антибіотики в Україні продаватимуть за електронними рецептами.
Ця система ще розробляється, але у МОЗ розраховують, що з 1 квітня вона почне працювати.
На першому етапі електронний рецепт потрібен буде для інсуліну та нарковмісних препаратів,
згодом перелік препаратів буде розширено.  Крім того, буде посилено контроль за видачею ліків за рецептами в аптеках.
Зокрема паперові рецепти повинні будуть зберігатися протягом року для перевірок Держлікслужбою.
В Україні має запрацювати ринок сільськогосподарських земель. Земельна реформа запроваджуватиметься поетапно.
З 1 липня купувати землі зможуть тільки фізособи-громадяни України з обмеженням 100 гектарів.
Лише з 2024 року площа землі з правом продажу збільшиться до 10 тисяч гектарів, а купувати ділянки зможуть також юридичні особи.
Це робиться для того, щоб українські фермери встигли взяти кредити, якщо вони зацікавлені в купівлі сільгоспугідь.
Бо нині через кризу та пандемію більшість тих, хто справді працює на землі,
не мають достатніх можливостей для інвестицій.
Розрахунок за сільськогосподарську землю має бути лише безготівковим з перевіркою походження коштів.
Забороняється купувати землю у 50-км зоні від кордону. А банки взагалі не зможуть купувати землю - лише брати у заставу.
У 2021-му планується глобальна реалізація судової реформи, запевняє президент Володимир Зеленський.
Як він висловився, у деяких суддів Конституційного Суду,
які хочуть зруйнувати антикорупційну структуру в Україні, нічого не вийде.
Зеленський стверджує, що вже підготовлено багато законів і українське правосуддя буде переформатоване.
При цьому в ЄС розкритикували компромісний закон про відновлення кримінальної відповідальності
за недостовірне декларування, яке раніше скасував Конституційний суд.
Згідно з новим законом, корупціонерів, які збрехали у декларації, не садитимуть до в’язниці,
а максимальна санкція відповідної статті передбачає покарання до двох років обмеження волі.
Євросоюз вважає ухвалений закон недостатнім і таким, що потребує змін.